you've sold your first screenplay and
then you have like 20 more about 20s
good yeah okay about eight to ten that I
think are ready to be sold or made or
something like that and then I've also
written been hired to write oh okay yeah
so of those 20 have you sold any more or
you've just been hired to write others
that were more like spec yeah like I've
been hired paid to write a script for
people so I've that's happened like six
or seven times and then my personal
scripts other than options which some
people are like well that's a script
sale but I think of that differently I
think of an option as an option of a
script sale as a script sale because an
option River it back to you you know
they're just paying for the time to try
and get it made so they might pay you
five or ten thousand dollars for a year
or two years and you can't really market
that script or sell it anywhere and then
if they can't get anything going then it
comes back to you so I consider that a
little bit different but if you sell
your script you've sold it that's it
it's done so these twenty scripts how
often do you look at them and where do
you keep them oh I still have hard
copies of a lot of my scripts like in
some box somewhere in the back of my
closet and but I do have everything or
mostly everything on did I even have
someone like the square disks oh wow
topping is a hobby disk that I need to
get like pulled off of there I had
someone do that because they wanted a
script that they knew I had written and
I hadn't looked at that script in
forever and they're like oh my god but I
need the other version you mean the one
that then the floppy this right uh do
people still get do you know someone who
can get it off and so he actually did
know us this guy you know there
there's always that guy there is houses
little on the back of somewhere and he
was able to put the floppy in and
transfer it yeah and get that script off
house like so yeah but they're all you
know online or sometimes that you know
them to myself a friend of mine said you
should always just email your script to
yourself
so that'll always be somewhere in
cyberspace that you can just dig it up
if you need it when you look at your
scripts is it ever painful not because
of your being critical but you knew
where you were at that time in your life
and you know what prompted you writing
that ah yes there's definitely scripts
that have some I don't know if painful
anymore is the right word but definitely
some kind of bittersweet emotion there
are people like I definitely have
characters that are named after people
and there are experiences that are in
the script that are real in some of them
so I'll think about that and I'll think
about that time and I'll think about who
I was and all of that
so I'd say bittersweet not necessarily
painful but definitely bittersweet yeah
right well I know I've heard a lot of
authors say that they've written about
people they've known and that once that
book or movie came out that those people
never knew it was them because they
never saw themselves like that oh that's
interesting you know I think it was Anne
Lamott was made one of the people I
heard there were other writers too that
said they just don't recognize
themselves that's interesting I don't
see themselves yeah that's that would
probably be true I think of any of my
care you know I don't even recognize
myself and you know my brother was
saying that's you I didn't recognize
that as myself even I was writing it and
you know that but this is the you
character right cuz I thought that there
was a little bit of me infused in all
the different characters at that time
and he was like yeah but this one's you
Wow
it is me he's like that's why you can't
be real
you